Choose all the
relationships that
are described by the following
equation-- y is equal to 7/8 x.
All right, let's look
at these relationships.
Relationship A-- a
bouquet of 8 daisies
cost $7 at Flora's Flowers.
A bouquet of 12
daisies costs $11.
The equation describes
the relationship
between the number of
daisies, x, and their price
at Flora's Flowers, y.
So let's look at scenario A.
So our x is the
number of daisies,
and our y is their price.
So when we get 8 daisies,
they say it costs us $7.
When we get 12 daisies, they
tell us that it cost $11.
So let's see whether this
relationship right over here
is the same as this
relationship right over here.
So if I were to take-- so let
me write this right over here.
So here, it says y needs
to be equal to 7/8 x.
So let's figure out
what's 7/8 x is equal to.
So if I take 7/8 times 8--
well, that's going to be 7.
Let me write this down.
7 over 8 times 8 is equal to 7.
So this checks.
7/8 x is the same as the
price that they gave us.
So so far, these two
seem consistently,
at least based on
this first data point.
Now let's look at 7/8 of 12.
Let's see, if we divide
12 and 8 each by 4,
this is going to be the same
thing as 7 times 3 over 2,
which is the same thing as 21
over 2, which is equal to 10.5.
So if y were equal to 7/8 x,
12 daisies would cost $10.50.
But we just learned that
12 daisies cost $11.
So these two things aren't
equal to each other.
So this is not the
same relationship.
In this scenario, y
does not equals 7/8x,
so we can rule this one out.
Let's look at relationship
B. There's a 12.5% discount
for every item at Crazy Joe's.
The equation describes
a relationship
between a given item's
price before the discount
and after the discount.
So here, they're
giving us a percentage.
And this equation
right over here
it's written as a fraction.
So let me at least convert
this into a fraction,
and see what kind of a
fractional discount this is.
And maybe I can
construct an equation,
and see if that equation is
the same as this one here.
So 12.5% is the same
thing as 12.5 over 100.
And if we multiply the
numerator and denominator by 10,
that's the same thing
as 125 over 1,000.
Now let's see if we can
simplify this a little bit.
If we divide the
numerator-- well,
actually, it looks like
they're both divisible by 125.
We divide the numerator
by 125, we get 1.
We divide the denominator
by 125, we get 8.
8 times 125 is 800 plus
200, which is 1,000.
So this is the
same thing as 1/8.
So really, there is a 1/8
discount for every item
at Crazy Joe's.
The equation describes
a relationship
between a given item's
price before the discount
and the price
after the discount.
So let's just think about that.
The price after
the discount, based
on the information
they gave here,
is going to be
equal to the price
before the discount
minus the discount.
So minus 1/8 of
the original price.
Well, what's x minus 1/8 x?
Or another way of thinking
about, what's 1x minus 1/8 x?
Well, that's just
going to be 7/8 x?
So this relationship
is the exact same
as this one over here.
The price after the discount
is 7/8 of the original price.
So we can feel good
about this one.
These two are the same.
Let's look at scenario C. And
I will do scenario C in orange.
A ticket to the paint
ball arena cost $7,
and comes with 8 paint balls.
Every extra paint ball costs $1.
The equation describes
the relationship
between the number of paint
balls x and their price y.
So let's look at this.
We'll do something similar
to what we did up here.
So we'll have x, which is
the number of paint balls.
And then we have y,
which is their price.
And then we will
think about what 7/8
x would have been equal to.
And let's see if y
is equal to 7/8 x.
So when we get 8
paint balls-- so
x is the number of paint balls.
So when we get 8 paint
balls, the price is 7.
And if we take 7/8 x-- so
7/8 times 8 is indeed 7.
So in this scenario,
for this data point,
it is true that y
is equal to 7 x.
Now let's get a couple
of other data points.
And we might have
to construct these.
So every extra
paint ball costs $1.
So if we have one
extra paint ball--
so we have 9 paint
balls-- we're going
to have to pay 1 more dollar.
We're going to have to pay $8.
And so, what's 7/8 x here?
So 7/8 times 9?
Well, we don't even
have to compute it.
This is going to be something
that's going to be like 63/8.
64/8 would be 8.
So this is a little
bit less than 8.
But the important point is
that 8 is not equal to 63/8.
y does not equal 7/8 x in
this scenario right over here.
So this equation does not
describe all of these data
points, so we can rule that out
Finally, they say the
equation corresponds
to the graph following graph.
So let's see if y equals 7
x corresponds to this graph
right over here.
So what we're really
saying is that for any x,
y is going to be 7/8 of that?
And the easiest one is to
see when x is equal to 8.
When x is equal to
7/8, x would be 7.
When x is 0, 7/8 of 0 will be 0.
And so, linear relationship--
if we have a line,
and if it goes
through the origin,
it is a proportional
relationship--
that the ratio between
the x and the y-axis
is always going to be the same,
or between the y and the x
values is also always
going to be the same.
And we know that that
ratio is the correct one.
The ratio of y to x
throughout this line is 7/8.
Here, it literally is--
our numbers are 7/8.
Well, we can even
take other points.
The ratio of 3 and 1/2 to 4 is
still the same thing as 7/8.
So this relationship,
relationship
D-- the relationship
described by the graph--
does coincide with the
relationships described
by this equation.
So I would go with B and D.